the national debt now exceeds 20
trillion dollars it happened after
President Trump reached a deal with
Democrats to allow the government to go
deeper into debt in that meeting we
agreed to pass an increase in the debt
ceiling Schumer called it a really
positive step forward he likes it
because more debt means government can
spend more and Democrats love spending
more Schumer wants no cuts to
entitlement spending and more spending
on Amtrak solar subsidies Obamacare even
the f-35 it's always more and
Republicans well they like spending -
the House vote to increase the debt
limit was 316 to ninety one of the few
who voted against it was Thomas Massie
he understands how important debt is
when you walk into my congressional
office the first thing that you see is
not a picture of my family or a picture
from my district you see a dethklok's
square right there staring you in the
face I put that up the first week that I
got to Congress number one to remind me
why I came to Congress four and a half
years ago
well you're failing yeah well I'm trying
okay if only a few more would try
today's piles rarely even make
suggestions as to how we might address
our debt our unsustainable increasing
debt they just keep spending more
increasing the debt as if nothing bad
can ever happen the increases are so big
I had to leave the building to graph
them less than 5% of the economy
here's world war one his World War two
used to go down after Wars but now even
in peacetime it only goes up pretty soon
we're up here how are we gonna pay for
that it's crazy
imagine you and I had a credit card debt
which was higher than our national
income well that's what places like
Greece have now that's what we have and
nobody cares they're gonna start caring
when they start looking at the the
dollars that they're gonna have to spend
and then what no one knows exactly you
can pull a rubber band and stretch and
stretch but at some point something bad
is gonna happen what will that be
I assume Congress will just have more
money printed to pay for things like
it's bigger military and much bigger
Medicare and welfare state
what will happen next maybe wild
inflation like they've got in Venezuela
this is not that unusual Zimbabwe
printed more currency to pay its bills
to now we have billion dollar bills from
Zimbabwe this today is worth nothing it
could happen to us
none of us knows when this will blow up
to prevent the crisis all Congress would
have to do is slow spending increases to
the rate of inflation but they won't
even do that they just raise spending
and raise it until something bad is
going to happen
you